hello I'm Sylvia and I'm a children's
author and this is my first book I got
really lucky with two amazing agents who
left their big agencies and formed their
own fired
come on must be like children they just
won the Trailblazers Award for their
pioneering for burning forests do you
book this let's not spoil it
to say elephant dies at the end yeah
yeah not see it coming but after it's
been on it's murdering rampage spree it
was really the only way which is better
obviously if you have a choice between
my book and I too enjoyed this by Diana
Wynne Jones
it's the balanced balanced rubbish
rubish real cover just a whole range of
words get West this one slick glossy
that's right off the children's books
that I loved as a child I still up now
and I don't think you should be trying
to write something for children that's
we're incredibly twee animals and coats
come from it's quite classist as my main
beef i don't really relate to any of the
characters or get what the arc is it's a
big thing that noah put animals in right
thank you Chris I challenge you to rap
about Diana Wynne Jones no no that's
fine yes fine the cognitive development
of humor okay oh so self-aggrandizing so
Diana Wynne Jones of the cognitive
development of humor and elephants let's
drop that beat and do this got the
bookshelf in your home crest Amenti
series father Diana Wynne Jones dwj
that's our initial you got the brown
position
the books are official I take this one
y'all safe for me it's Diana Wynne Jones
the Berlin conspiracy the best writer of
magic that is the reaches of Nea says
Neil Gaiman my son the page is like
about Maurice oh wait stop there instead
of a bookmark you had a loose hair
saying oh yes wanna get the paragraph on
the little keratin in there I feel such
a laugh it's got a very long gloves is
never absurd fantasy ends its most
inventive oh yes I heard that you need
to read all of them even though she dead
so the praise will not go to a head here
she just a skull in the six feet under
tomb or maybe action well I'll bring it
down in this room you feeling sad your
brains inflamed you're like no I didn't
know she's dead and so ashamed but when
you're like two you couldn't even read
or when it came to humor yeah you never
succeed you never understood the joke
told by ladies or blokes they'd be like
punchline and you just look at them and
joke and say was that how you sounded
when you ate slice bread slice bread
given to small children I tell a joke
stand-up and it just kills them they
roll about laughing and piss their pants
but that's just because they're in
content incontinence they just wear the
nappies because the cognition does not
put the brain in the humorous position
humor us that's a bone maybe in your leg
yeah but humor is something that works
in your head when you ate by the age of
seven you can understand joke sarcasm
when tossed off hand but no satire
unless you kind of trying to be a liar
saying how the standby sweats off to
perspire and we realized you just
telling porkies baby air go and get some
green sleeves and go back here try and
make the sense you know they're cancer
resistant that the elephant they never
catch it they got the cancer fire alarm
genes like 20 but we just get one I'm so
keen it's really true and knock it out
the park what animals that cancer
resistant sharks and also another one I
tell you were fact smaller than the
elephant the naked mole rat fur and
elephant yeah they never forget they go
and get a check-up from the local
dr. ovett and say hey I've got always
swelling mate and so they put a hand up
and check the prostate I'm just saying
that you know what I like I know in the
book you say they're not really scared
of mice for scared of ants yeah I read
the word I'd be like very like Sherlock
I'm so observant the heart we got I
would Sparkle if the dog would be bad
maybe spoiler alert if the child reads
it and they hear the rap they get her
it's so fun
ya know forward planning I see an
elephant yeah roaming the Savannah
I'd be like not to sit on your right
early throne and talk about elephants
hey Sylvia where can we find a book 2nd
of June 2016
we're um book shops online probably also
online or from a car boot